e
version de ce forum entre
intervenants et police.MeMeMeMe.
Richard Vallières, un homme
condamné à 8 ans de prison
pour avoir volé pour près de
dans le Centre-du-Québec, devra
finalement payer une amende
équivalente au montant du vol.
La Cour suprême confirme
la peine initiale infligéeéeéeée
par la Cour d'appel. On discute
de cette amende importante
avec l'avocat-criminaliste
Marc Labelle.- Bonjour.
montant de l'amende est-ce que
combien on a volé et ça équivaut
à l'amende?
- En fait c'est que l'amende
compensatoire donc il est
question c'est un espèce de
tutti de sentence qui vit tout
seul. Dans le sens où ça fait
parti de la peine mais ça a une
vie complètement indépendante.
Ce que le juge doit décider,
s'il décide d'imposer une amende
compensatoire, c'est quelle est
la valeur, quel est le profit
que le criminel a tiré de ses
évaluation, de ce que ça
représente ça c'est l'amende
compensatoire. Ce que la cour
suprême a décidé aujourd'hui,
c'est que c'est la valeur dans
exemple c'est 9000 quelque
218 millions, Monsieur Valère a
admis qu'il avait fait desnsnsne
a dit que la membre
compensatovavavavavalait au
profit. La cour d'appel avait
seseseseseseseseseseseseseseses,
conséquemment c'est 1 million.
urururururur suprême a rétabli s
faits.
- On comprend que si ils sontgée
amende de 10 millions c'est-à-1r
l'équivalent de 10 millions dans
ses comptes de banque?
qu'on ne peut pas confisquer les
biens. Les produits de la
criminalité, s'ils peuvent être
confisqués c'est ça la règlent.
On commence par les confisquer.
Sur le palais confisqué, bien là
ça membre compensatoire. La
seule distraction que le juge a
ses est-ce que j'en impose une
ou pas. Ça il peut décider s'il
constate qu'il y a des profi
mais il n'impose pas l'impôt
l'amende compensatoire
s'il décide qu'il impose la
valeur du profit qrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
l'accusé.
- Ici quand mê u u u u u u u u n
montant considérable on se
comprend. La cour donne 10 ans à
Richard
fonctionne? On appelle le
percrererererererererererererer0
millions?
- Non ce n'est pas tout à fait
V V V V V V V V V V V V V V V t
cette période-là et peut faire r
une partie, il peut payer de. ..
Cependant, s'il ne paye pas cesx
ans d'emprisonnement à être
libérations conditionnelles
notamment au tiers de la peine
on peut être libéré est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des client
la purger ma peine de prison
tant pis pour l'amende. Parce
que quand même 10 mill
dollars mois qu'il y ait
vraiment de fortune de planquer
quelque part.
parce que les périodes
d'emprisonnement à défaut de
paiement, quand c'est des sommes
importantes,stststststststststst
bien. Par contre, ce qui entre
en jeu c'est le percepteur des
amendes. Asisisisisisisisisisi
on on n'est pas capable de
rencontrer ses évaluations de
paieme
aujourd'hui, le programme de
iriririririririririres serait
applicable à un cas comme celui
de Monsieur Vallières. Le
maximum qu'il pourrait faire,es.